[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to another
episode of allegedly it's me matthew
cole weiss and we have two special
guests today one since the 0 is out I
don't know what he's doing banging
something uh we have something something
animan object it could be it could be
and uh that is the voice of mo Mandel
comedian and you have the show you a
special on seeso right I have an hour
comedy special that just came out on
thursday on c so called negative
reinforcement and yeah very cool well
congratulations thank you so much yes
the other guest is far more impressive
and i'm a big fan of his are you take
hurry yeah and our second guest is mr.
john c mckinley who you may know thank
you guys thanks for having currently on
the new show stand against evil but for
many years on the show scrubs but also
in films that I kind of like didn't
remember that you were in and then he
looked up and you're like oh yeah he was
the guy he was Marvin wall street he was
in platoon he was in point [ __ ] break
with yeah pretty yes he was and I think
did you get punched out by Gary Busey
first and last time I've ever been hit
yeah and the rule for me is you have to
after that because I think it's a
mistake to get hit in movies you have to
get killed and I'll tell you why if you
are disposable enough or not enough of a
threat for someone just to coldcock you
then you become that guy and I think you
have to get killed I've never been hit
since so you mean your characters status
can be equated by how quickly they could
just punch you in the face without
anyone caring that you get hit and
you're that guy yeah yeah you will you
write your cuz your character in that
absolutely right anybody buddy you were
the [ __ ] boss guy where you wanna
know he's a [ __ ] but he's Stern
preserve the jacket piano plays whose
fantastic by the way but I think he was
you know introducing this kid to the
bank robbery capital of the world did
did you see the remake by the way did
you approve in the first place that they
were going to do a remake of point break
my neighbor and dear friend Laird
Hamilton is in it and he's great but I I
didn't know what the film was about I
thought some of the stunts the wing the
wing stuff the the second unit wings
if they shot was astonishing yeah but um
I didn't I didn't get the movie ya no me
neither we'll get into that one of one
of my favorite parts of yours is just
one more like you seem like God like
it's amazing to me one thing I always
just admire about you as an actor and I
really have a very big man is even if it
is like not the starring roles like you
maximize so much in a small amount of
time like in office space your character
has always been one of my favorites and
you don't you aren't even like that and
to get to the movie but it's so
memorable just the odd that look in your
eyes when he says he's not a Michael
Bolton fan it's just like you have this
ability to be like you like to be so
serious and that's why it's funny
because you're not like in on the joke
which I find is a community who dabbles
an acting so difficult to do we all had
to audition for Gary Cole's part in
office space and then Mike said do you
want to play one of the bobs and in the
script they're very very innocuous and
so I just went down to we were in austin
texas and i was only there for four days
and mike just put as much slack in the
leash as you wanted to hang yourself
with but i was like um i'm gonna drive
this thing did you ever get to spend
some time with Michael Bolton after that
no never never met him no no I'm just
thought maybe clears if he had seen that
yeah I'm just really would love to hear
what he thing is the way they said
you're so dead seriously i celebrated 3
tablet she was a great for his brand it
probably was absolutely i think the guy
sold 90 million records yeah i don't
know if he really cares but my mom
honestly had a poster of michael bolton
in her closet when I was growing it i
would have to google i think he sold 90
million records yeah yeah yeah he's done
very it was a stud of time he went
pretty good let's jump into this we got
worried about it many other yeah we as i
said as i described we have a little
different kind of format and so we'll
just hoppin around one if you don't mind
yeah far away which is will each have
three minutes to tell a story okay I'll
go first yeah you have kids right I do I
have a 19 year old son an eight-year-old
daughter and a six-year-old daughter wow
that's big and if in your stories we
could not use the r-word it
would be much better for me no no [ __ ]
and [ __ ] otherwise I kind of like I
wouldn't use it um so I have a brother
who's 11 years younger than me and when
I turned like 12 I guess and he was
about one I won an award in the county I
grew up in a very small town outside of
Philadelphia and so uh I won this award
which was awesome and they had a big
ceremony and it was for I did not to
toot my own horn but I organize a
letter-writing campaign to the soldiers
over season during the Gulf War and so I
was getting this whatever so I have a
brother who was one at the time and that
night before I get mail my ward we were
playing hide and seek because it was a
good brother whatever he tripped and he
fell on the fireplace bricks and cracked
open his skull right in the middle here
was awful was terrible but all I could
think about was you're ruining my big
moment which was a terrible thing to do
yeah and they're like get him to the
hospital i'm like what about me what
about me and he's bleeding in on their
my I was really mad at my parents I was
like so are you you're not coming like a
roof and they're like you can still go
but we're not coming we're going to the
hospital and I just such a [ __ ] brat
I was just like okay well fine so I they
called the principal this of my school
at the time who was there to support me
in my behalf which was really cute
because when I got there um he he had a
little sign for me that said like 'hey--
a mat or something along those lines and
my parents weren't there anyway i gave a
speech and in my speech I thanked my
brother for cracking his skull open so
that he could steal my thunder and I was
like I oh it was almost in the getting
booze but I was like such an entitled
little brat at that time and then I
walked off and I was just like I took a
picture by myself and I was just like
mmm maybe I should find out how my
brother's doing right so I had my
someone pick me up and drive me to the
hospital where he was ok oh yes that was
at one of my the only award I've ever
received actually in represents a
sweeter story because he was ok yes oh
if you
not only God very different story now
granted I have done 70 podcast episodes
so far so I have used a lot of my good
material already but but this popped in
my head because my brother now lose with
me and you can still see the scar and
every time I say it i'm reminded of that
hard moment but i had a similar kind of
thing where my brother's a lawyer and he
has somehow gotten to know Jerry Brown
our governor through legal stuff and I
dropping well for him it's not a present
for me but for i was on a sitcom for a
brief period of time for four weeks and
i get cancelled but when it got picked
up I got to go i went home my parents at
low party and during that party Jerry
Brown called my brother and he had to go
to the room and talk to the governor for
two hours on his cell phone and then
take off the drive to his house to talk
was of the economy I'm like are you
serious I wanted ridiculous it like this
no way if you have like intellectual
Jewish parents that's not trumping your
little sick right exactly that's pretty
good just dominant yeah all right go
ahead mo you got right well okay I was
just trying they do Hollywood if no I
don't even know if this is a good story
I would just sort of like feeling text
me hey you got three minutes ago tell
story about Hollywood okay so i was
thinking of just the weird way that you
know a lot of times disaster in this
town can cannot can ultimately be
something good so i was saying when I
forget I'm a big fan you're acting and
I've done some acting but it's always
been something I'm like it's
nerve-racking to me little bit when I
first moved down here in 2008 i would
get these sort of opportunities to like
meet with you know bigger level people
and it was always terrifying to me and I
would always screw it up horribly like I
remember I wrote a script that somehow
it got to the always sunny guys and they
were like you go to meet with him and I
never met with anyone famous before or
anything it's a 2008 terrified I stayed
up all night working on what I was going
to say drinking red bull and I was just
didn't sleep I was out of my mind and
added like crashing my car over to the
meeting and having like cab from the
accident to the meeting jacked up on Red
Bull it was a disaster so every time I
had a chance to meet with anybody I
would just melt I got the audition for
Damon Wayans I start shaking I just
couldn't do it you know so I had my
first maybe not the right career for you
I've gotten better about it was
terrified you know it's really you when
you go from essentially doing open mics
in San Francisco like i was doing in
your ear i was working as a talk at a
taqueria and a bar you know your career
is at this
teeny level and then all the sudden you
get like a manager like where's the
three in the rooms and you're like like
it's terrified so I'm air i gotta i
think was like my first general which i
didn't know what that meant to this day
i'm not sure i still know what that is
but was meeting with the head of cash
you know for some reason it's just so
they can get to know you see get to know
you anything specific yeah sees
basically you know it's a weird thing
you go in there and you sit with these
casts the head of casting a Warner
Brothers it was you know and I'm driving
out there am i I'm just like nervous
nervous nervous and somehow this is crew
but I literally somehow like kind of
like [ __ ] my pants on the way to think
but yeah I legitimately did somehow like
and I somehow I was just so nerd I used
to like had this problem before we go on
stage a totally goes into my mouth and I
and I kind of did on the way there and I
was like and I was like at the lot
basically I was like pulling a lot i'm
like what what am I going and I and I'm
sorry this is so dirty but I literally
had to pull into like a restaurant
parking lot take off my underwear drive
by garbage throw the drive to the meet
and be like what am I gonna do what am I
gonna do what are we doing and I had to
go into the bathroom like used to clean
myself up as much I could and I think I
needed a good job and then I'm just in
the room like so i'm from san francisco
and i'm a comedian and in the holes I'm
like are they just smell are they just
like what the widest guys smell seems
like like I'm just like freaking out
like what what is heaven and you know
like you're like they're not gonna tell
me probably smile of a sign like I'm
done like I'm done in my mind I'm like
this is it this is the end of it this is
just this is where more gets around like
Oh an actor [ __ ] his pants into me like
just don't hire this [ __ ] movie and
somehow it turned out to be thinking but
like I really remember driving by a
garbage can drop it for the first of my
life ever doing this underwear into the
doves are pulling directly into a lot
for the first time there's been about
first and so far only time i also got
very nervous on the way here but no but
anyway so that wouldn't you know the
casting directors gonna hear this girl
oh now i make but no but this is was in
mark always loved me after that seemed
to bring in for a lot of stuff that so
was like it was actually the one of one
of the only really great general means i
think i had and it probably should have
been alright so a drive map i'm gonna
give that one to mow wish you can
vicariously not not from the the potty
level but it is hard being an actor it's
hard yeah and when i was i was the
reader when someone comes in to audition
for something
in the room usually is the casting
person less and less the director now
there's usually just a camera the
casting person and hopefully a reader
and I was Oliver Stone's reader for
about four films oh well you wanted me
as your reader because I love actors and
I'm really going to give you I'm going
to do better than whoever you practiced
with last night whether it was the
mirror or a good friend and so I started
to compose this theory on how we actors
come into the room and especially when
Oliver is the room in the room because
that's a it's a big deal and actors do
things to themselves when we're going to
see a big mucky-muck we are even harder
on ourselves and so my theory was that
actors bring in two things into
auditions 1 of 2 we can't have both the
first is pig pen and pig pen is a
character in Charlie Brown who is
preceded and in fact surrounded by dirt
wet and the dirt is all around him and
that's what a lot of times we bring in
when we subvert ourselves or when we're
scared to death we're scared to death
all the time and sometimes actors would
come in to meet Oliver and the first
thing they'd say to subvert themselves I
don't know why we do this but they'd say
my aunt died in Philadelphia last night
I had to take the train down I never
really got a chance to look at the sides
but I really wanted to meet you well you
just lost Oliver yeah the meetings over
yeah and you didn't need to say that but
we we are Pigpen the opposite of that so
you have a little I call at Elvis dust
when Elvis dust comes in its combination
of being at the right place at the right
time that's the variable you can't
control preparation some kind of
self-esteem hit that's working some
sense of entitlement like I belong in
this movie but without trespassing into
arrogance and so it's see that it's this
really ephemeral cocktail that if shaken
or stirred too hard comes out wrong well
in my case that would be Liberace does
probably barrace de la bière that
doesn't matter what the dust is when
it's magic yeah I went in to meet David
Fincher on 7 yeah for a role that was
written for a latin male now I you can
catch me as a lot of things you're not
going to distress me the Latinate
no but the producer of the movie was
also the producer of platoon and Arnold
became a kind of a mentor for a bunch of
us in the in the Philippines and he
wanted to bring me in for seven he was
the producer on seven and so I read the
script I thought it was the greatest
script that read my life and I'm like in
California is this tiny little guy in
the SWAT team but it didn't matter is a
great script you want to be in grade
school yet and so I went in and I had
Elvis dust all over me and I can't tell
you why but David rewrote it from a
Latin male and he changed it to John
McKinley is seven stole the best script
you've ever read no it's funny we were
talking about this the other night the
sixth sense of the best grip we ever
read we all we all went in to audition
for what Donnie Donnie Wahlberg Donnie
Wahlberg would play everybody all of us
because otherwise it was local hires in
where they were in Philadelphia yeah
everybody else was local hire and so uh
the only other principal was Donnie's
role and we all auditioned for that and
that script when you put it down you
realize that what test yeah you want to
throw that stuff I went to see that
movie on a date and we showed up at five
minutes late so at the end when the
route was revealed like that is the
dumbest twice I've ever heard why would
I have assumed he was dead and then
afterwards you're like well I got shot
the beginning of like oh he did he get
shouting that makes a lot more sense but
it was like we left we talked on all
night you know you're on a date just rip
apart we were like buddy otic plot hey
guys matt here and i want to talk to you
about see so which is one of the
funniest sites around and i know that
because i'm looking at one of the stars
of C so right now my our special
negative reinforcement on C so C so also
has a ton of other hilarious comedy
specials as well as their own original
program it's awesome so C so the site
you can go to were you for you it's
NBC's digital comedy platform it's only
three ninety-nine a month and if you
sign up right now using the promo code
Theo yes you get two months free wow
that's awesome yeah and also you get a
lot of back shows right like you can
watch older episodes episode and s
well things like that yeah yeah all the
episodes of The Tonight Show we're on
there with Jimmy Fallon and they have
original program to such as from a new
special by mo Mandel negative
reinforcement that's a very good point
what's that call negative reinforcement
oh ok negative reinforcement on CDs oh
ok i watched on amazon fire stick and
you watch on roku wow very cool i mean i
know they have other shows like hidden
america with Jonah ray harming my wife
take my waist why Tamara Esposito very
funny take my wife that's if it was me
yeah a jillion dollars please no it's
not and it's something you can stream
anytime anywhere correct yeah so if I'm
just like well I don't want anywhere
like I mean if you're in like you know
shangri-la like I can't really speak to
that I have no plans to go to show that
he's good it's good and it's also this
is one of the best things it's ad free
like there's no commercials so those
commercials speaking as weak as I do a
commercial commercials they're the
winners after this one this one's great
for cc so everybody go to see so calm
use the promo code Theo get 20 get two
months free and after that it's just 399
and check out most special which again
is negative reinforcement and see so is
spelled SE ESO and it's NBC's digital
comedy platform it's really good alright
so see so calm now back to the show
[Music]
now we are into round 2 which is our
interview and I want to talk about stand
against evil but first I want to ask you
a question on your you've done as we
said you have done tons of movies also
the rock which is an it you've done a
lot of like cult classics to on in Ron
tomato do you know will of your movies
which one has the highest score and
which one has the lowest i would i would
say my rotten tomatoes yes our worst one
is the sequel to the Highlander
Highlander number two you got it that
was worse that's the worst of it that
was just a doing before that weird I
mean it was great shooting if they're in
point is ari's for like four months
that's a circle right here on you got
your half there and now number one and
the highest score is it a combination of
reviews plus comments yes so the best
reviewed have to be platoon you would
think but it is actually a very merry
muppet christmas alright became the
hospital we're doing scrubs that's very
very very Muppet Christmas I would know
I would never have gotten what's it like
being part of all these like classic
films and do people recognize a I'm
curious how people react to you when
they meet you everything's demographic
and geographic so when we were just down
and we're back in manhattan for
comic-con to promote stand against evil
in New York everybody's it's going to be
wall street and set it off the with
queen latifah and and and jada and those
those are going to be the two in New
York when you're on a college campus
college campus I just was working in in
Bloomington doing a flick at IU
everything is office space in scrubs
yeah it's amazing college kids are still
into office space I mean that's like
what 20 years since I came out and
there's no what is it I don't even I've
ever watching in college cuz I was
dating the production managers daughter
Karen the DV was her name and she
brought me there to show this me and I
was like this movie I was like oh my god
this is amazing I've never seen it
before our people normally cool to you
because some of the characters you play
our little intense do that do they get a
little too intimidated by you the only
time things ever get tricky is if you
stay too long if you make the mistake of
staying too long it like a if mo and I
went to on for monday night football and
you stay there too long when guys drink
a little too much courage
they get a little handsy until I always
leave early yeah yeah I'm otherwise is
great with which line do they do the
drunk guys yell at ya double your lines
it's it's all over the map it's stuff
from office space I get a bad feeling
about it from from from platoon chicks
and Nixon chicks from Wall Street you
know there's there's some stuff the guys
start to bark and yeah those are rich
man's problems by the way speaking of
which you're on a show that had a great
run for a long time and now about to
jump off on another one right stand
against evil is a new horror comedy on
IFC independent film channel and it when
it's really cooking and I'm one of the
producers on it and the whole things
about tone and what I mean is I don't
know if you guys remember an American
Werewolf in London yeah but what's great
about what what what they did with
Landis did an american werewolf in
london is a straddle two tones and the
two tones are comedy and horror and the
reason that's so hard is because say
you're doing the Exorcist you're not
going to break a joke in The Exorcist
and then the opposite is if something's
too funny then then the threat there's
no consequence from the threat because
it's scooby-doo when horror and comedy
really worked together it's frickin hard
and when it's cooking it's great and so
the guy who created this Dana Gould oh
my gosh Simpsons yeah one of the
founding writers in the Simpsons and
when I was just an amazing state of
comedian mazya he's just this side of
genius yeah absolutely i mean book smart
and and and and dark his comedy could be
so dark Daniel's dark yeah I'm sure and
so that the high-concept or the the slug
line on stand against evil is is Clint
in Gran Torino hunting witches or Archie
Bunker fighting witches huh and so I
play this guy who in the first two
minutes of the pilot we see his lost his
wife he's lost his job and all he wants
to do is sit in his lazy boy recliner
have thousands of beers and watch The
History Channel but he can't even do
that because 172 witches are trying to
kill him and hate when that happens and
there's this small group in this show
that'll be a witch a week yeah and it
opened last week to the it got better
reviews than platoon for God's sake
platoon won the Oscar can you tell like
when you're on a set do you have like a
good instinct like something's gonna be
good or bad or you kind of like do
shocked when with yes I it is a good
question i think it should be reflected
in the overall tally sometimes sometimes
I sometimes I can but most of the times
I can't because like it's almost
tantamount to a horse in the Kentucky
Derby with those those blinders on
hopefully you're staying in this really
finite bandwidth and just working on
what we're doing today Johnny Cusack and
I did fat man and little boy which was
about the making the atomic bombs and
we'd Paul Newman was down there with us
and the guy who just got nominated for
the the killing field and for the
mission Roland job he was directing it
and all these great actors Bonnie
Bedelia and it was a huge paramount
drama about about Los Alamos and how
Johnny and I wrote our speeches for best
supporting actors and the film tanked
not because it was offensive anything
was just boring so that's a long-winded
answer to your I have no idea hopefully
I have no idea well it gives me like and
you're a big picture little picture what
do you you're fighting a witch in an
imaginary world how do you emotionally
get yourself in position where the the
emotions are real and and there's no and
like you really are like is there a
process you just able to do it I mean
though I'm so process-oriented it's not
even funny I keep a rehearsal space in
Los Angeles and I have a teacher and we
just break the scripts down just to
their bare bones and we take them apart
and see what what resonates and then put
it back together let me ask I mean you
I'm sure you've worked over the years
with actors that haven't taken the craft
as seriously as you do and how does that
jive with you when that happens um
everyone's why would have guest stars on
scrubs once the things started yet
percolate and get going and some actors
would come in and just kind of want to
just go and wing it and you can remember
medical terms are Latin and so you're
memorizing Latin and so when actors
would show up and one actor in
particular I'm not going to tell you who
because it's it's not a nice story but
he kept showing up
you know your sides are a reduced
version of the pages we're shooting this
day and there I don't know they're there
three by five and so actors have them
and they're they're looking at them
until right before we go and then we go
and this one actor couldn't remember his
lines I don't think he couldn't remember
him he didn't know or didn't take the
time right to bust his ass and was
pretty cavalier about it and I'm i
really love that I still love the
process of acting and how hard it is and
and trying to peel it back to like I was
suggesting to mow finding out what the
frick were doing here what are we doing
and with that in mind I told this actor
who just insisted on having his his
side's right up until action I just told
them and I've now done this a lot it's a
horrible thing but I said to him you
know what you should do is just keep the
sides in the frame because we're just
going to be on me listening because it's
infinitely more interesting than seeing
you struggle with words because you
you're not doing anything in the context
of the piece you just you're trying to
regurgitate Billy Lawrence's words and
so i guarantee you we're going to be on
me listening and it's going to be twice
as engaging mmm the actor started to
memorize his life yeah well it's gotta
be a thing too if you're on a show like
scrubs were you just you must love it by
this point I mean it's like it's it's
you it's a baby that you've seen grow
and then have people kind of coming to
disrespected you know I've heard other
actors talk about yeah i buy that yeah i
buy that sure yeah yeah there's some
preparatory um kind of egoism in there
that that the five of us kind of lifted
and Billy Lawrence you know between Zack
and Donald and Sarah and and Judy kind
of lifted that thing up and yeah you
know now we got it we got it to a good
place we're 12 million people a week or
watching which would make it the number
one show on TV right now and but it's
not and so yeah you i would i would hope
that you'd come with your a-game what is
something you wish you would have known
starting your career in this town that
that would have saved you duress pain
would have made it easier any kind of
piece of information
this is going to sound like a rich white
guy that's fine all three of us a rich
white guys some of us spiritually rich I
haven't really rushed studio apartments
or although we're all white let's all
tell you y 2 i'll tell you what it is
and it just occurred to me that
everything's i wish somebody just told
me everything is gonna be okay hmm that
is rich why I picked this day but I
definitely others areas aim I that's
that everything's gonna be okay it is so
can I infer by the way you're gonna go
do something else and that'll be fine to
say so I can infer that there was a lot
of years where john c mckinley was
beating himself up wondering if i do i
have is this gonna be enough like you
why am i not farther all the stuff that
everybody basically does yeah you're
also guilty of these I mean I was
chasing films around the plant i was
doing for a little while there if you
look on IMDb i was doing five films a
year just chasing it mmm you if you
though i didn't have really a criteria
for people he's go like how do you pick
films i'm like what a preposterous thing
or a direct right right i just i love
when people say things like that how do
you how do you pick your films like how
about offer the word often yeah that's
how i pick my films I've ever say that
there Zoe for even moved to LA wells
like I'm not gonna go out for
commercials or any drama what I really
want to fight and now they do good daddy
you're like oh my god i don't i don't
want to end up working at subway next
month like it work i worked at a place
on Mac called Mary Lou's on ninth street
between fifth and six all the way
through grad school I'm attend where you
grad in the theater program which was
great but I when I my mission statement
and this is going to sound ridiculous
but I was making too much money at
marylou's it d incentivized you going on
that fourth audition today and so my
mission statement getting through NYU
increasingly as the years went by also
went anyway you here just did you go to
my mind is fantastic i applied 10 we
feel like this way I feel like I'm also
part of the club but I just decided I'm
not gonna I'm and when when mo said
about subway ice aside I'm not gonna
wait tables anymore and so I to I went
on the 6th audition on Wednesday up at
Donna de seda which was the voice-over
commercial place where who won the
Academy Award for for Fargo Franny
mcdorman for any mcdorman and I will
always be all
turn ative couples because we were never
Ken and Barbie and so that bring in a
bunch of Ken and Barbies for dentine or
whatever it is I'm making it up but and
then they'd bring in kind of the
alternative shop and Franny and I will
always feel really a couple so great
with commercial stations in particular
you could see where where you fall on
the looks matter whether you go in you
look right like oh really we got me know
where we're using the wrong product
ringy Franny and John and uh granny I'm
going back to scrubs have you heard
there any chance of any kind of reunion
or anything you know especially now that
there's so many like Netflix bringing
back shows and things like that was that
something you would ever hope for or no
no no there's a hundred and ninety-two
episode 100 and 200 episodes for nine
years and so it begs the question if you
were on that show and you were lucky
enough to be on that show for nine years
and you didn't get something out of your
system I'm eccentricity that you wanted
to exercise what the Frick we await in
here Rose was that show or you'd be like
this show still on like oh my god for a
while I would watch if I go this must be
a rerun and I'm like this is even good
lord that's how violent i don't i don't
see Zack I don't I think everybody
that's done I can't speak for anyone
right but I would Billy Lawrence I think
wrote a musical or had a musical written
about it and I think that's there
there's there's a a dozen episodes of
scrubs that are really a plus and that's
miraculous yeah so I mean because you've
most been on that doing a half-hour
television show not the four camera
because they're very hard as well I just
did one with my friend Skylar Astin and
they're really hard but doing a
single-camera half-hour it you work 14
hours a day and it's impossible that
you're even getting it done or that it's
actually good or that it's actually
funny Brian since no one's in the
everyone's tired everyone's grumpy you
just got rewrites handed to you on the
way to the set and it it becomes a grind
I love the grind so how do you as I act
like yourself with a process-based how
do you deal with new sides coming to you
on the set
I own scrubs the first five seasons I
worked really the hardest I've ever
worked in the offseason trying to get
some fundamentals down for dr. Cox which
is the character's name and so that no
matter what Billy Lawrence threw at me I
could I could run I was so competitive
that no I want it to be the guy that no
matter what he threw my way I was going
to crush it that's so thatís I didn't
want it going over to Donald or Zach or
Kenny or kneel or Judy or because
they're all so goddamn talented that
they would have run with it I'm like no
no no no no no you Billy wrote the word
cotillion once and I was it with some
kind of put down of Zack and I got to
use the word cotillion on national
television I was like give me those I
want those the nuggets I want them I
want a fair catch those those are the
ones I want and so the process for me
the only way to do it was in the off
season where everybody's sprinting to do
films know it's just like what are you
what's the buddy what's the point you
just did we at one point we're doing 26
episodes a year and it was like we can
do a film on hiatus like no let me pose
to talk to the shrink and I'm gonna love
my wife take the kids to pottery that's
what I'm doing in the height is I as we
gotta wrap up round two but I have a
couple quick questions I want to fire
off at you that I want to get out get
out number one you're in great shape I'm
fighting gravity whatever exactly what
do you do what's your team and and
surfing really pick up kids and put them
down all right that's good one what are
you afraid of it weird noises that I
don't recognize in the middle of the
night because we're located out in the
middle of nowhere and if it's not the
radiator going off or because you know
that sound yeah it rated your tix or you
know that sound when leaves bloke rope
but when that so Stan versus evil must
be the standing at dealers were the
perfect showcase you can imagine there's
a lot of that going on well there's
witches yes a weird sounds alien sounds
in the house when I'm there by my so
nomina but when the kids are there I it
gets me do you miss soap opera work
doing a soap was the greatest thing ever
be another world what's awesome i
remember that and the funniest part
about another world was it was out in
brooklyn on the stages out in brooklyn
they would always send a teamster for
you in a you know sedan to pick you up
and bring you out there because from
your house yeah yeah
we need you to their own time yeah and
because of the amount of pages you do on
a soap 60 pages a day and which is
impossible and but when you're wrapped
you get a subway token we're not really
getting oh good luck that's an answer
for you and you feel like just the man
that's funny once it's it was yeah yeah
yeah it's hilarious okay two more Malibu
mob is this a real thing yeah Melville
mobs a group that works out and lips
together and I would say it's Laird
Laird Hamilton gabby reece chris chelios
Jenny Cusack although he just moved to
Chicago Johnny McEnroe and John McEnroe
van and Johnny Johnny I love it yeah and
DB sweeney was a was a Tony downs dancer
was the senior member but he doesn't
live in Malibu anymore oh so do you have
like meetings no just work out and eat
dinner that's cool all right and then
lastly and I know you're friends with
Johnny Kuzak tell me something about
johnny kuzyk I wouldn't know uh he the
when you saw him during the cubs games
uh none of that was an act he bleeds
Chicago blue also he must have been that
must have been as a highlight yes yes a
life highlight needs to go to games with
his old man with dick Cusack who we'd
produced a film the dick wrote and who
passed and Johnny's the the heaven that
John was in during that that three-game
when they came back from three to one
that was I've never seen him happier Wow
okay what is like the role that you
haven't gotten yet that who keeps you up
at night or at least inspires you to
play I have not gotten to play Who I am
in real life I have not gotten to play a
special needs dad yet yeah and so I
would love to get a script where it's
not a woe is me pity party script about
our special needs community the down
syndrome community and specifically I
would love to be able to flesh out what
is what it is to be a special needs debt
was that a was it a big learning curve
having to learn that profound yeah
profound I know you're also ever you're
walking down a runway correct yeah we
have our
a group that I got with this which is
very aggressive kind of advocacy group
out in Denver is called the global down
syndrome foundation and we have this
great every day you know the all special
needs and cancer everything everyone
else has to be constantly raising money
and so our big fundraiser gala is a
black-tie event that Matt Dillon my
friend Matt Dillon is going to come join
us this year is this Saturday in Denver
and it sold out so I'm not pimping it
and we have our it's a it's a be
beautiful be yourself fashion show we
have a runway and our all our models are
people with Down syndrome and then so I
bring in a bunch of my friends and the
models are escorted by different
celebrities last year Alec Baldwin came
out and joined us and and we just we've
had a lot of success with some of my
friends coming in Jamie Foxx is on the
board with me because his sister diandra
was born with Down syndrome and so it's
a magic night and we raised a bunch of
money all which is for research we've
started a hospital adjunct to a Denver
Children's Hospital job Denver
Children's Hospital is called the Linda
cernak Institute and it only serves
people with Down synovial hospital on
the plan that the only serves people
with Down syndrome primarily young kids
life and it's a research-oriented group
and this is our big weekend so we're
going to fly in thursday and the whole
family will be there and pretty exciting
weekend force there's not many people um
I've interviewed through my years every
single actor there is out there my
journalism years there's not many people
like when I said you were coming on
aside from oh my god he was in that
movie and this and that he they said did
you know that he does a lot like he's a
for Down syndrome and stuff so you
that's that's that's like a badge of
honor that that you are known for that
too I mean I wonder that's I want to
advocate for people who can't advocate
for themselves yeah and that's that's
our group yeah because of our different
challenges with language and never mind
our other challenges but in our Down
syndrome community it's very hard for
our our people to advocate for
themselves hmm well my last question on
that I'm just curious what is the
biggest misconception about the down
syndrome community or the disease
disease no it's not a disease
it's a chromosomal your 21st chromosome
triples okay I would say the biggest
misnomer is that they ever did anything
wrong to anybody to be able to be on the
receiving end of language like [ __ ]
and [ __ ] and there's no consequence
for that language so in other words if
you use the n-word or if you disparage
people in the gay or lesbian community
or in the Jewish community or my Italian
friends or Puerto Rican friends there's
a consequence for your vitriol whether
it's a boycott or a confrontation
there's a tax on that there's nothing in
the special needs community we're trying
to make it through the day you know our
kids have the triple threat of of
seizure disorders cardiac problems and
and digestive problems and so when that
group is disparaged it makes me want to
rip someones esophagus out and so we
started a campaign called spread the
word to end the word and it you it's
hopefully it just inspires a
conversation right and so people like
what's the word its [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
like oh I I didn't know that was it's
like oh good now we're having a
conversation right and then when you
know when [ __ ] like are you not
supposed to use that word now when
jackass is like Ben Stiller put it in
that movie tropic thunder yeah you know
if that had been the n-word the film
would have been shut down right or if he
had despaired his own heritage if that
had been something the Germans said
about Jews the film would have never
opened but there was no consequence for
disparaging the special needs community
what'd he say 17 times in 3 minutes
right I did it just it it seems unfair
so I want to advocate for those who
can't advocate for themselves well good
on you man good on you yeah really man
that is uh one of my good friends just
had a special needs child his first kid
she's like one years old now and I was
first time just seeing him like as a
father and then also all these other
issues challenges it's like this is just
like weird genetic thing where she can't
swallow and it's like salivary problems
and it's like it's like it's one of
those bizarre things with dogs like
we've only seen this like eight times
well also a Jew whose 610 another
awesome a cobija nada bien Maccabee
war area life not you as I was raised
you if you were in short hills new
jersey when you kill ya I don't think
McKinley is like Irish yeah fallen
through right i'm a i'm a de facto
member of the tribe hey Zach always said
I was a member of the tribe okay we'll
take you you damn right over hello know
that we have any choice no I'm in
Hamburg a good memory seems like a more
powerful force it either but eat me up
to an immaculate he's also got the tough
Irish side to me that we can't say
anything about Irish ooh look at that
Wow terrified um so okay that's the end
around too so you have to pick a winner
of battle I know it's tough to further
questions yeah the questions um I we're
now going to side with you because we're
Mecca beans together yeah yes sorry but
Molly I am Jewish I know but you didn't
give me the full I didn't get me shoe it
up enough no no you are getting your
jeweler than me up so low that is absurd
that is a compliment that is a
compliment but absurd than John Seely
things I he's more jewy than me why for
actors I'm not gonna use the word Joey
but I ads very Jewish all right have 20
seconds to prove your Jew it up just
getting out um okay I [ __ ] a dump
thrilled that he paid that assess
[Music]
yo Matt yes this is mo Mandel over here
hey mo Mandel I watched a hilarious
comedy specialty tonight on seeso which
is the NBC digital comedy platform okay
it was called negative reinforcement by
comedian named mo Mandel mo Mandel the
night I don't know if I'd hurt him
either but it was hilarious and it's one
of many great comedy specials originals
that are on seeso and get this they also
have their own original programming like
hidden America with Jonah ray take my
wife by Cameron Esposito as well as
every episode of SNL ever what do you
see so exactly so it's a streaming site
see so calm you can also watch it on
roku and amazon fire stick and it's all
comedy 24-7 no ads 399 a month then I
know too good to be true get this you
sign up now using the promo code Theo oh
which i think is named after our good
friend Theo I would hope so quite or
amazing coincidence you get it two
months free Wow okay cool so it's funny
it's all comedy [ __ ] all comedy all the
time all right place for comedy it's for
comedy nerds by comedy nerds and it's
just amazing and not just cuz I'm on it
but you are on it so everybody come and
support mo Mandel go to see so calm se
es oh yeah and as you said use promo
code Theo get two months free and after
that it's just three ninety-nine a month
but it's well worth it because it's it's
yes also got like every episode of Monty
Python Steve Coogan's Alan Partridge the
other original office with Ricky Gervais
great light it up yeah it's got justice
a lot of awesome stuff sounds like a
good investment if you want to laugh
it's like imagine for Lotte could make
you laugh for a month straight oh okay
yeah I got it easy so calm there you go
now back to the show alright so this
takes us to our final round round 3
which is a mini challenge based on our
guest and since you are on the show
stand against evil which is about
witches and whatnot we decided we would
each have to give our most evil laugh or
voice you gotta go first right glasses
off
solid you like a nice sort of like
reverb that's a leader at the turn yes
oh really set that bar I always want to
go work out when I do that one yeah you
know that y know sorry don't think about
that no ammo for he did like the high
pitch which thing so it's like I don't
want to go that zone you know I got a
kind of go Igor or something like that
so sort of like yeah Charlie take like a
backdoor approach you what we'll do it
together ready let's do it all right one
two three yeah Makka begin come back ah
that was one you're real killer show
yeah I usually try to get weird with it
that was some seven show they're good
yeah okay all right well congratulations
mo you what I really brought rat even I
really brought to that a little bit of
Elvis dust call back headed the whole
podcast Wow okay well congratulations
sir thank you that voice was a little
too natural for me actually so well I
have you know I okay okay uh so John
thank you so much for coming in here
thank you have me thanks mom thanks for
talking about everything and stand
against evil on IFC and anything else
there were any other films nothing
coming out got a bunch but that you know
the will go to that next now about Stan
against evil which I I saw the first
episode of and love yeah they sent a
copy to me i love that is really really
subversive i was gonna say what can we
expect through these eight episodes just
wrong I'm in here at a better chance is
wrong yes it's just wrong and it feels
good being wrong yeah and it doesn't
placate political correctness and it's
uh just really f top you know what
that's awesome in a day like literally
tomorrow's election day and we have like
crazy stuff going a jackass number one
and a gentleman whose everything she
says and I'm gonna vote for but
everything she says is the most rehearse
thing on the plans actly but it's like
until stand to me exponentially is more
welcomed in refreshing yeah um between
those two uh stand for president she's
gonna win in a landslide you think yes
she is I think in the bottom of the
ninth win in a landslide hope so let's
hope so if not landslide you heard it
here I i I'm hearing it there I once
again did not get it together to
register to vote and I feel terrible I
have been tweeting I can you they can
take away weights take away that win
that's not okay okay he do you have a
she's gonna carry the statical yeah so
did I I never feel bad about MO it's a
copy I feel bad about I always mess also
some huge measures on it that's true so
uh if if the other guy wins were
bringing standards not going to he's not
going to but if he does they doing the
hypotheticals ok but not happening it
doesn't win he's gonna need a job I
think Stan against evil to he plays like
some sort of weird zombie creepy evil
not me so perfect I know maybe such a
permisos creatures go just go away the
games I agree neighborhood he spawned
that spawned him and it's go away yeah
completely yeah okay so well stay tuned
for that one yeah but everybody watch
Stan against evil and again thank you so
much this legendary actor it was
interesting hearing so much about your
your craft and your experiences in your
personal stuff and I'm very enrapt not
at all so thank you so much i can thank
ya thank you all right bye guys will
talk to you later
[Music]
you